I believe that we've been living in a we
live in a technological society but we
constantly act as though it as a
financial society everything that is
going to be of critical importance in
the next 20 30 years is whether there is
a lot of progress in technology and
science and yet our priorities are
massively geared towards saving the
financial system rather than making sure
the technological system works better
and so for example we had a seven
hundred billion dollar bailout for the
banks in late 2008
even though it would have been
unthinkable to give seven hundred
billion dollars to Internet companies in
2000 or 2001 and I think that's sort of
a double standard reflects the ways in
which our priorities are skewed towards
finance and away from technology even
though it should be the other way around
nothing has changed in the last year
since this financial crisis has unfolded
to to reflect a change of view on this
site you know if you look at the
policymakers in Washington DC of the 538
people in the Senate and House only 11
have backgrounds in engineering or
science and so we have people who do not
understand that windmills don't work
when the wind doesn't blow or that solar
power doesn't work when it's dark and
and it's based you're basically you
basically have policymakers who are
effectively on living in the in the dark
ages in terms of the way they're
thinking about the most important
questions of our time
financial innovation and technological
innovation are both good to the extent
they involve real innovation and bad at
the extent they do not involve real
innovation the thing that is very tricky
about financial innovation is that it's
often hard to know whether it's
innovation or whether it's something
that's dependent on some kind of
temporary and unsustainable
unsustainable trajectory so innovation
in housing in financial engineering
around that was probably ultimately
unsustainable because it depended on
ever increasing debt ever increasing
leverage their versions of technological
innovation that may be unsustainable as
well so if you have some innovation that
leads to an extraordinary environmental
damage it may look like you're making a
lot of progress but it turns out not to
have sort of long-term compounding
aspect to it some forms of financial
innovation have involved misallocation
of resources to my mind
people are being scapegoated a bit too
much in the finance industry and I think
the question we need to be asking is not
whether there's been too much financial
innovation but why there has been so
little innovation in other areas
well financial innovation true financial
innovation I think ultimately helps many
different aspects of society creates
deeper capital markets makes make some
money accessible - and capital
accessible to people who otherwise would
not have it so I think I think true
financial innovation actually helps a
lot of people again I think the critical
question one needs to ask is whether
we've been seeing genuine innovation or
this temporary detour driven by policies
and a culture that had a preference for
ever increasing debt and leverage
I think it is far too early to tell what
kinds of innovations are going to be are
going to come out of this crisis I'm not
personally convinced that crisis or
instabilities always the best context
for great economic growth or anything
anything of that sort to the extent that
certain kinds of business models have
been discredited or thrown into question
that's that's obviously um that
obviously may open the door for other
things to be done but I think I think
that we will we will not only know the
answer the question of what exactly is
being created as a result this crisis in
twenty years time
the question about what sorts of
innovations were likely to see in the
next 10 or 20 years depends a great deal
on what people do the pessimistic view
is that we are living in a society that
depends on innovation and science and
technology but that is is actually not
focusing on these things nearly enough
and that as a result we are headed
towards a extended period of stagnation
and very slow growth in throughout all
the nations of the developed world the
more optimistic view is that we somehow
figure out a way to to restart the
innovative engine that's probably got
installed and and my version of this
would be that we go back to where the
50s and 60s ended and look back at the
great technologies people were pursuing
the time space robots artificial
intelligence the next generation of
biotechnology and and you sort of look
at where people thought the future of
the world was going to be in 1968 and we
try to take off from where where things
got detoured around that time